um we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to david p
here's a really good question
that came in
about the obsession from many on the
right with trans people take a listen to
this
hi david um as for why
people are so obsessed with trans people
i myself am not trans but many of my
best friends are
it's actually really based in white
supremacy
in that being a straight white man
is their entire identity and if the
gender binary
it doesn't exist the way they think that
it does then
their entire there's an entire
existential crisis that they can't deal
with because their entire identity is
based on being a straight white man
so it's a lot more complicated than that
and the gender binary is very
complicated across multiple cultures but
that's my two cents so there's a couple
different things going on first of all i
i think
some people don't like it when i say
this
i really could not care less about
gender and sexuality in the sense of it
impacting
my uh opinion or conversations that i
want to have with people and what i mean
by that is
i
i'm not being pejorative when i say this
i'm really bored by all of this stuff of
what identity and who's what and who do
you date and who are you attracted to
and what's your gender
i have so many things that i tend to
find of interest to talk about with
people regardless of their identity
that i find all of this stuff really
really boring i treat everybody with
respect
i don't care how you want to identify
i don't care who you're attracted to i
just it's just not interesting to me i
consider all of these just people's
personal choices
and i'm fine with whatever as long as
you're not hurting people committing
crimes the things i'm concerned with or
people who regardless of their identity
are just not good people that those are
my concerns okay so for me it's like i
just i just don't care do whatever you
want see whoever okay now that doesn't
mean i ignore the fact
that there are people targeted and
treated terribly because of their
identity now why is it such a point of
obsession for so many on the right right
now it's trans people um it's it's in a
sense there's two things going on one
it is much more
what's the word i'm going to say it's
can it's now much more accepted to be
gay and lesbian by the way lesbianism
has for a long time been the most
accepted that's the least offensive
that's for a long time if you sort of
like rank the things that the homophobic
transphobic etc right-wingers are angry
about
lesbians is usually the thing that
they're least angry about then you've
got gay people and when it comes to gay
men
they have to a great degree kind of said
okay gay marriage is legal uh you can't
fire people for their real or perceived
sexual orientation anymore we got to
kind of ease up on that and also i think
that the public opinion has shifted and
more and more people even right wingers
are generally
uh
tolerant if not absolutely fine with gay
people as a general thing although
homophobia still exists so now you've
got trans
and within trans
you have a number of different aspects
that people can choose to become enraged
about there's the trans adoption part
there is the characterizing trans people
as predators this is the bathroom stuff
remember that was when bathrooms were
the big flash point it was all about
well
biological men
will
lie that they are actually
uh wanting to exist in the world as
women simply to go hang out in women's
bathrooms and girls locker rooms and
it's like of course that's not happening
and also
uh acting like a predator would get you
in trouble no matter what you have as
gender identity it just it didn't make
any sense but that was one aspect that
they could
they've been pushing the gay men or
pedophiles thing for a long time
wrongly so
but it seemed like they had a really
specific way to do it with trans people
that was less overtly transphobic to
some and so they could get away with it
i think that that's one component of it
number two
it's entered the political milieu for
the right because of transports and
donald trump openly you know doing his
weight lifting mimicry and the entire
thing about transports so that's another
aspect that is entered in if you have a
competition
uh
among men
and some of the men are gay it doesn't
give you the same opportunity to claim
things are unfair
that the narrative about
trans athletes has given so that's sort
of like another aspect to it
um and then beyond that they they seem
obsessed to some degree
uh because the focus has been on
cultural issues more specifically lately
and so they don't really have policy to
talk about i i think it's sort of like a
little bit of all of the above that's
why the right has become so obsessed
with uh with trans people if there's
elements of it that i'm missing let me
know we have a great bonus show for you
today
andrew yang's forward party the third
party has now formally launched we will
talk about it what is their policy we
don't know yet but they're going to
announce it very very soon secondly the
biden administration is offering to
return to russia a convicted arms dealer
to get brittany griner back that's the
female basketball player who's been
imprisoned in russia for a period of
time now there is now a negotiation
happening we will talk about it and
number three two former police officers
have now been sentenced for violating
george floyd's civil rights this is
going above and beyond um the initial
trial and we will talk about that as
well all of those stories and more are
available on today's bonus show to get
the bonus show you've got to be a member
that's the only requirement you sign up
at joinpacman.com
you will instantly have access to the
bonus show and of course if you would
like a discount off of membership use
the coupon code big voting 22. we will
see you then or on the friday show